hola vamos a resolver algunos ejemplos
sobre el mínimo común múltiplo para que
terminando el vídeo vayas al módulo de
ejercicios sobre el mínimo común
múltiplo y los hagas por ti mismo
entonces vamos a empezar con un ejemplo
quiero tomarme el mínimo común
múltiple entre 10 y 8 entre 10 y 8 cuál
será este número y bueno te voy a
enseñar dos formas de obtener el mínimo
común múltiplo de dos números uno de
estos lo llamo el método de la fuerza
bruta y creo que es bueno porque te
ayuda a entender qué significa el mínimo
común múltiplo de un par de números y
después de esto vamos a ver un método un
poco más elegante así que el método de
la fuerza bruta consiste en poner aquí
los múltiplos de 10 y los múltiplos de 8
así que bueno empecemos con los
múltiplos de 10 los múltiplos de 10 son
10 también tengo el 20 también tengo el
30 al 40 al 50 60 70 80 90 100 y así me
puedo seguir y seguir y seguir con más
múltiplos de 10 pero vamos a ver si con
estos ya es suficiente ahora me voy a
fijar en los múltiplos de 88 por 1 es 8
qué otro múltiplo tengo 8 por 2 16 8 por
324 8 por 4 32 después tengo el 40 48
después tengo el 56 56 + 8 64 64 + 8 72
después tengo del 80 al 88 y si no puedo
seguir y seguir y seguir poniendo más
múltiplos de 8 pero entonces ya que
tengo múltiplos de 10 aquí tengo
múltiplos de 8 ahora lo que voy a buscar
son cuáles son los múltiplos comunes y
los múltiplos comunes que veo aquí es
primero tengo el 40 común múltiplo común
aquí tengo el 40 con un múltiplo común
pero además tengo por acá al 80 con un
múltiplo común al 80 como un múltiplo
común pero recuerda que yo lo que busco
es el mínimo común múltiplo es decir de
todos los múltiplos comunes que encontré
cuál es el mínimo y bueno pues la
respuesta es 40 40 es el mínimo de estos
múltiplos comunes que encontré es de 18
por lo tanto
podría poner que mi respuesta es 40 40
es el mínimo común múltiplo entre 10 y 8
ahora date cuenta que 18 son números con
los cuales podemos encontrar de una
manera muy sencilla cuáles son sus
múltiplos sin embargo si es un número
mucho más grande tal vez te convenga el
método elegante como es el método
elegante bueno lo primero que hay que
hacer es tomarnos al 10 aquí y vamos a
encontrar todos sus factores los
factores de 10 son a pues es 1 también
tenemos al 2 también tenemos al 5 y por
otra parte tenemos al 10 también tenemos
al 10 ok ahora vamos a hacer exactamente
lo mismo para el 8 cuáles son los
factores del 8 bueno pues tengo al 1
también tengo por acá al 2 también tengo
por acá al 4 y por acá tengo
ok entonces lo que hay que hacer es
fijarse detenidamente cuál de estos es
el máximo factor común bueno de hecho
aquí solamente tenemos dos factores
comunes 1 y 2 y cuál de ellos es el más
grande pues serían 2
entonces me fijo en el más grande de
estos factores comunes que tenemos de 18
y ahora sí ya puedo escribir que el
mínimo común múltiplo entre 10 y 8 quién
es bueno pues va a ser exactamente lo
mismo que 10 por 8 10 por 8 agarro estos
dos hilos multiplico ya esto lo voy a
dividir entre el máximo factor común
entre el máximo factor común de estos
dos el máximo factor común de 8 y de 10
que por cierto es el máximo común
divisor esto es lo mismo que el máximo
común divisor de 8 y 3 y cuánto es esto
bueno 10 por 8 es 80 y encontramos que
el máximo factor común entre estos 2
2 y 80 / 2 es 40 por lo tanto ya podemos
concluir otra vez que el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 18 es 40 por un método un
poco más elegante en lo personal
prefiero más el método elegante porque
nos sirve para tomarnos el mínimo común
múltiplo de cualquier cantidad de
números nosotros multiplicamos a todos
esos números y los dividimos entre el
factor común más grande de esos números
sé que no te ha dado la demostración
formal de esta fórmula que estoy
utilizando pero en un próximo vídeo creo
que me tomaré el tiempo de hacer la
demostración formal ahora date cuenta
que el método de la fuerza bruta sirve
bastante bien para números pequeños pero
si yo te dijera toma el mínimo común
múltiplo de números muy grandes tal vez
encuentra a los múltiplos de cada uno de
esos números no sean nada sencillo y por
lo tanto esto se pueda volver bastante
difícil en este caso funcionó porque
tenemos los números que conocemos
bastante bien sin embargo creo que el
método elegante es mucho mejor porque es
un método que nos sirve sean
en los números además ten cuidado no
vaya a ser que en el método de la fuerza
bruta pases por alto algún número